[Musique]
nous ciblons 15 millions de personnes
vaccinées d'ici avant l'été même avec la
meilleure organisation et où les
approvisionnements qui arriverait en
temps et en heure nous ne pourrions
avoir vacciné toutes les plumes tous les
pots de tous les publics fragiles d'ici
à l'été
nous sommes en mesure de vacciner un
million trois millions quatre français à
la fin du mois de janvier probablement 4
millions de français à la fin du mois de
février et 70 millions c'est à dire la
totalité de la population française
d'ici à la fin août ça dans une
circonstance que je précise c'est si la
totalité des vaccins que nous avons
commandés sont validées par les
autorités sanitaires européennes et
mondiales
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est ce que ces variants sont sensibles
aux ex dans des premières données une
étude américaine d'il ya deux jours
montrent que sur le variant sud africain
il ya une diminution de l'efficacité du
vaccin d'environ 40%
on a affaire à un virus qui est qui et
diabolique et qui est beaucoup plus
intelligent qu'on ne le pense
[Musique]